now for our first panel of the day we
thought we'd better define what we're
talking about so the topic of that panel
is what is intelligence not a small task
that you're enhancing secretary-general
of the Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences
has as moderator on his panel he has
Barbara gross of Harvard University
Helga Novotny who's professor emeritus
at 8a ha in Zurich edvard moser who is
one of the 2014 Nobel laureates in
medicine and Maggi Bowden from the
University of Sussex you're on the floor
is yours thank you Adam
good morning everyone so we heard some
very interesting talks and video
comments on intelligence but what is it
really
Margaret you've thought a lot about this
can you give us a helpful definition the
definition certainly a description
I think intelligence is being able to
move towards and in some cases achieve
your goals some of which conflict with
one another
in a complex and largely unpredictable
environment which certainly all the
higher animals can do and which at the
moment virtually well no artificial
intelligence can do not least because
the vast majority of AI systems at the
moment only have one goal they try and
do one thing and they do it very very
well very often but they don't negotiate
lots of mode of goals and motives and I
think that's what's involved in
intelligence thank you I think we can
come back to artificial intelligence in
a little while but let's hear first from
our the other panelists here do you
agree with this description would you
bear anyone be a volunteer to condense
it into a definition in a few words
Barbara I'm not going to define it
precisely but to start by quoting a
United States Supreme Court justice
asked to define something somewhat more
risque and he said I know it when I see
it
know it when they see it I think
Maggie's definition or non definition
description brings it brings up very
important points which is that it's it's
not a single capability but many
different capabilities in the ways in
which we understand the universe and the
word itself goes back to a latin word
which means understand but it's an
understanding of a complex sort maybe I
can just add that in my own field which
is psychology and neuroscience this
complex this concept is so complicated
so broad that we actually don't really
use it so in neuroscience no one really
talks about intelligence because it
covers so much that although we all feel
we know what is meant by this concept
it's it's too too diverse hope that you
would by now I mean I mean last year we
won the Nobel Prize for discovering the
Positioning System GPS of the brain I
thought you would announce the cells
that account for intelligence in the
brain it will take a while apparently
let me take you back a couple of
centuries to the Chinese philosopher Lao
si and he defined intelligence as the
ability to understand each other but he
added to understand oneself is wisdom I
think what he did not foresee could not
foresee is the enormous progress we have
made in understanding ourselves but not
so much in the philosophical sense but
in the sense that we have heard and seen
of I'm trying to understand how the
brain works how the mind works and what
is our challenge ahead is to take this
this one step further to turn it not
just into understanding but into wisdom
namely anticipating understanding better
the unintended consequences of what we
do we only better at that now then we
were say at Monte where this times when
that the new
take that we heard in the beginning was
written I think definitely but we also
see that the number of challenges is
mounting and this has to do with the
complexity of the modern world in which
we live our inability to foresee and
this is how complexity works the way how
parts interconnect and we do have better
ways of looking into this
interconnection simulation models etc
etc but there's still a long way to go
so yes we have made tremendous advances
but we also face no challenges and I
would add perhaps one dimension of
intelligence that I think we have to
come to grips with and that is social
intelligence and by social intelligence
I mean a better understanding of how the
social order works and when Lars
mentioned in the beginning of his talk
the world has changed has been
transformed in the last couple of months
for us living in Europe and in in the
world and I think we also have to start
thinking about how we can enhance social
intelligence
I worry sly slightly here because
intelligence now in these few minutes
has come to encompass essentially all of
human civilization and interactions
between humans a market can we somehow
divide it or reduce it to two specific
more more defined activities that
perhaps the advert could find the nerve
cells for in a few years time well you
can focus on this activity that sort of
problem this sort of problem for example
you can call them academic disciplines
but we all know that there are these
artificial Chinese walls between
academic disciplines so you start out as
an economist for example thinking you
only worry about those sorts of problems
but you find out actually you've got to
start thinking about perhaps
neuroscience perhaps
meteorology so yes you can try and focus
and it helps you to focus helps you to
ask and answer questions otherwise you
couldn't have done but you can't get rid
of the complexity the complexity is
always there and if you forget about it
eventually it'll come back and bite you
for Neuroscience Edward can neuroscience
contribute to this topic
consider it yeah I think I mean it's
really a revolution going on in
neuroscience today in the sense that
these most complex functions of the
brain are actually beginning to be
understood so I think we are learning
now how the brain or how the cortex is
actually computing what are the basic
algorithms and many of those may be
similar to all of these seemingly
diverse functions of the brain but I
think you're still just at the start and
it will take a while to figure out we'll
probably over the next year's get a lot
of data about from the brain but to put
it all together and to see what are the
really the principles by which the brain
work that is a much much slower process
but I definitely think it's going
forward and it's hard to predict what we
will know by 2050 for example how much
do you think is hardwired how much will
be specific cells and group of cells
that are there and stay in one place and
connect to each other like your grid
cells and play cells there's a lot that
is hardwired definitely but at the same
time what's so special about human
beings
compared to machines is that from the
very very beginning we interact with the
environment through lots of sensors
we're bombarded by information and this
is sort of put into the brain the brain
is rewired a little bit to adapt to this
and this goes on then for decades so I
mean the the answer is both
we are hardwired
there's a lot that is fixed but then
this is also adapted to functional
function optimally in the world so there
is some that's hardwired is some that's
learnt and by experience and repetition
and so forth can we construct a an
artificial intelligence system that will
function essentially as the human ones
Barbara was your thoughts about that
first I want to say that we don't need
to construct artificial intelligence
systems that replicate us there's quite
a good way of already replicating us it
works pretty well most of the time I
want to go back to the person who really
initiated AI Alan Turing who said that
the whole process of thinking was rather
mysterious
but by trying to understand it we would
learn a lot about how we think so
I think the the goals of artificial
intelligence are to understand
intelligent behavior and intelligence
and to embody it computationally but
that doesn't necessarily mean
replicating us I wanted also to pick up
on something that my co-panelists said
which is we now know from neural science
that the learning that humans do is
socially very very dependent on social
interaction and we see this in early
brain development I'm sure Edouard can
say more about this we see this in
learning of languages so that as we
build AI systems I think it's crucial
that we take into account the role of
social interaction even though we are
building a different species of
intelligent behavior so I think if I
have a concern about how we look forward
at intelligence it's that we not
overlook the social interaction which
really everybody has has brought up in a
sense we are stumbling into an
artificial future there will be a new
between the artifacts that we create
I being one of the most prominent ones
but the precise way of embedding this
into a social environment into the way
how our institutions function all this
is a kind of stumbling there is no
master plan out there there's a lot of
uncertainty on the way how we will get
there and I think it is this stumbling
into an artificial future that contains
an enormous potential but at the same
time we have to have the kind of
adaptability and the plasticity that we
have inherited but to translate it also
into is socially manageable forms so I
think that's exactly right and one of
the things we've learned in an area of
artificial intelligence called
multi-agent systems is that it's much
more difficult to build a system that
interacts with groups of people than it
is to build a system that just interacts
with groups of systems and I think going
forward it's going to be absolutely
crucial in the field and I would say
also in the neurosciences and in the
cognitive sciences writ large
not to focus on intelligence as in a
single mind but to look at the
intelligence of individuals in the
context of societies and communities and
of working together so I wanted to give
my answer to the eleven-year-old who
asked if a wonderful question of whether
AI was going to replace teachers and of
course I don't I can't predict the
future I can say that what we have
learned in the last decades about
artificial intelligences and teaching is
that it can complement teachers and
actually make for a better educational
system if you look at complementing and
working with people and with the
teachers and with the students rather
than thinking about replacing them so I
wanted to thank that student for his
question and we have a panel on the
future of learning discipline or it was
a related question we got from from
student in the audience I'm Rita
Krishnan I don't know if he's here and I
wouldn't say be able to see if your
raises his hand anyway the question is
is artificial intelligence an evolution
of intelligence itself that it brings up
of course the interaction between the
artificial and the biological and the
human that we touched upon any one would
water some thoughts on this hugely
important and exciting one with a hugely
exciting future to it yes whether it's
any more of an evolution of human
intelligence then you know Newton's laws
Darwin's theory whatever I don't know it
said there's another an example and as I
say a hugely interesting and exciting
one it seems from from what you all say
that human intelligence is still in the
driver's seat so to say but I wonder if
if the interaction between us and
artificial systems how that will affect
us how what impact it will have for
instance now that we have gps's in our
cell phones wherever it is will your
system atrophy to service that the Lord
what will happen to the great cells in
the future are you worried well of
course this affects us because we we
navigate in different ways but I think
what's so special about humans and human
intelligence if you use that word is
that you must can adapt to almost
anything that's the success that's why
there are so many of us everywhere and I
think just like any challenges that are
happened before in evolution humans were
led up to this to a level by other forms
of interaction
perhaps but of course for navigation as
such we'll always there's always an a
component of training and experience
and if you use then a GPS instead of our
own brain of course we navigate at least
in a different way but III think I don't
see it as a threat it will just change
in a different way in the same way that
mobile phones over just 10 20 years so
completely changed our lives how we
handle information but I mean people
learn in a different way people treat
information access information in a
different way I would say it's an
example of cultural evolution and
cultural evolution is much faster than
biological evolution but we also see new
and interesting intersections between
cultural evolution what we do and what
biological evolution has equipped us to
be able to move on we have so many more
social interactions now then 200 years
ago say ovide we're in touch with
millions of people around the planet and
each one of us with at least thousands
probably through digital media and and
in many different ways whereas my great
great grandparents probably saw the
other people on their neighbor forms and
that was it is that gonna change the way
our brains function and this is gonna
change the way our brains look the way
they're hardwired so I think as Edouard
was suggesting our brains are very
plastic and and we adapt and we adapt so
culturally also and I think we're seeing
that you ask the question of what
artificial intelligence to replace our
cognitive abilities I think they will
certainly change what we need to make
sure of and and we actually can control
this in some way through design is that
they make us smarter not dumber but they
really truly complement us and so I
actually I like the GPS example because
I'm a hiker and you know if you're out
of GPS range you better know how to
locate yourself without the GPS system
and I'm not sure about Europe but we
have these stories in the United States
of people who get in great
trouble because they think that their
phone will show them how to go when
they're up in the mountains and it
doesn't always work so I it's an example
of where you want not to think about
replacement but complementarity and I
would say to everyone who is a consumer
of these devices that you can ask that
they make you smarter and not less
intelligent so that's a wonderful
message too at which to conclude here
that after all mankind is getting
smarter perhaps in small steps but it's
moving in the right direction we just
have to hope that we're moving fast
enough to handle all the problems that
not against invention in the beginning
but I take it that there is a optimistic
message from the panel here and with
that I thank you so much for discussing
this difficult topic with us and I think
we all understood at least how complex
the topic is and how hard to define it
is but there is hope for the future
thank you very much